the goal should be that everybody gets a chance
to
read great books
and participate in the richness that humanities
brings us if you die of maliaria
you don't get that opportunity so absolutely
it's a wonderful thing that
that we get to experience those of us who
live in the united states and had resonable
opportunity
I love movies I love books and things like
that
I think we need to make it so that everybody
gets to engage in those thing and some continue
creativity that's wonderful
but that's more and goal then
the thing that enables
the equity most people that avreage in the
bottom billion
you don't get the read many books or see many
plays and and
so thats what I put my work into
I don't have the talent to create those things
but I applaud the people who do